So we knew when we looked at the proposal
for Donald Trump's Republican tax cut last
year, we knew from him
reading it that it would increase the budget
deficit.
There are good and bad reasons to deficit
spend.
We've debated some of those reasons before.
What we have a almost unanimous consent on
is that deficit spending to give tax cuts
to the registered Americans is not an economic,
economically stimulative reason to go into
debt.
So we knew it would happen and it has.
The deficit has exploded.
The numbers show it.
We've covered it before.
And so Donald Trump is now faced with exploding
budget deficits added to his China tariffs,
which have so deeply hurt farmers that the
federal government is now paying to bail them
out as well.
Just racking up even more deficits again,
as a result of the policies that Donald Trump
has chosen, chosen to enact.
So what is it that Republican Ted Cruz is
doing?
He's demanding a tax cut for the rich expedited
without even getting congressional approval.
Cruz sent a letter to Treasury Secretary Steven
[inaudible] asking that capital gains be indexed
to inflation.
Now this requires some explanation and I hope
that I'm going to do a good job of this because
these things are not always the easiest to
explain, to understand how this is a tax cut
for the rich.
You have to understand how capital gains normally
work normally.
Imagine that you buy $1,000 worth of shares
of stock and those shares of stock go up in
value to $5,000 the numbers are really clear.
You paid a thousand it's worth worth 5,000
when you sell those shares, you have 4,000
in gains and you pay capital gains tax on
the $40,000 that's easy.
Now to index capital gains to inflation means
that you add inflation to the purchase price
of $1,000 so in our example, imagine that
you paid the thousand dollars for those shares
five years ago, and in those five years there's
been enough inflation that $1,000 then is
like $1,081 today.
That's what I got when I used an inflation
calculator.
When you index capital gains to inflation,
you allow the cost basis of those shares to
be $1,081 instead of a thousand so what that
means is instead of paying capital gains taxes
on that full $4,000 you're only paying capital
gains on a little bit over $3,900 now, it
doesn't sound like much with those numbers,
but that's what's important about this.
This is a ton of money for the very rich.
The reason that it is effectively a tax cut
for the rich is that for most people, indexing
capital gains to inflation is a difference
of just a few dollars here or there.
86% of this action would go to the top 1%
okay?
Understand the scope of those numbers.
86% of the benefit of making a capital gains
index to inflation would go to the top 1%
at a cost of more than $100 billion over a
decade, meaning even more debt, which Donald
Trump told us he was going to eliminate.
The mere suggestion that this is an emergency
requiring executive action is laughable.
Now, this is one of those cases, let me be
clear, I would love this.
Over time more and more of my income has come
from capital gains of different kinds.
This is a change that would be great for me,
but it's an immoral change.
There is no economically defensible rationale
for doing this at all.
Nevermind the completely comical, farcical
assertion that this is such an emergency that
it should be done by executive order rather
than by actually getting a bill through Congress
and signed into law in order to do this, which
they probably wouldn't be able to do because
it is such a capitalist's handout.
The funniest, or maybe the saddest part about
this is that Ted Cruz is actually touting
it as a way to quote help everyday Americans.
86% of the benefit from this would go to the
top 1% the bottom 99% would then split 14%
of the benefit, and by the way, I think if
you looked at like the bottom 90% they would
get a small portion of that 14% I assumed
the lion's share of that 14% would go for
those between the top 1% and the top 10% and
meanwhile the minimum wage hasn't even kept
up with inflation.
Okay.
Understand the sick hypocrisy and crony bottom
feeding pond scum nonsense of this.
They say emergency, we've got to index capital
gains to inflation.
Meanwhile, the minimum wage hasn't kept up
with inflation.
The bottom half of America hasn't seen in
real terms, wage increase in decades.
What is it 30 or 40 years?
That's not an emergency, but indexing capital
gains to inflation is such a problem, such
an emergency that immediately we need to go
outside of the normal legislative process
and get an executive order in place.
These people are immoral.
That's it.
I mean, Ted Cruz has to be voted out, but
Ted Cruz is just a symptom of the disease.
It's way bigger than Ted Cruz.